I am sick of how mean the world is.
I'm sick to my stomach about it.
I think you are as well, I think everyone is.
Can we actually picture a world
where instead of infecting each other
with anger and upset and fear,
we're sparking waves of
kindness across the planet?
The pendulum needs to swing,
and the pendulum may indeed be swinging.
One of the top influencers on YouTube
is not a peddler of doom and gloom.
He's someone who wants to share
the amazingness of life,
and he does so withthese kind of,
crazily audacious stunts.
I'm talking, of course, about MrBeast
and his 200 million subscribers.
Many of his stories are anchored in generosity.
He is introducing a whole new generation
to the possibility that generosity
isactually really cool.
It's a beautiful thing.
Maybe the new mantra for the connected age
should be something like this:
"Be brave. Give what you can,
and then be absolutely amazed
at what happens next."